[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eines
meiner liebsten türkischen Gerichte ich
muss ehrlich zugeben als Kind mochte ich
das nicht so meine Mutter hatte so oft
gemacht und immer wenn uns das dann gab
es nicht schon wieder es handelt sich um
Karriere das ist ein ofengericht mit
Aubergine und Hackfleisch alles typisch
türkisch gewürzt und wirklich sehr
lecker ich muss sagen die älter ich
wurde umso mehr mochte ich jetzt und der
die Zubereitung ist eigentlich auch
recht easy und das Gericht sieht halt
super festlich aus finde ich habe jetzt
hier mein Gemüse schon mal schön
gewaschen ich trocknet das jetzt hier
noch und als erstes müssen wir die
Aubergine vorbereiten wenn du mich
fragst wo stehen die ganz großen
Mengenangaben
geworfen die steht immer unten in der
Infobox ich nehme jetzt jemand
Sparschäler
bestens vorbereitet heute so und jetzt
wird erstmal die Haut geschält ihr könnt
aber auch ein bisschen was an Haut dran
lassen also ja das sieht dann aus wie
kennt ihr noch Bananas in Pyjama voll
gerne guckt ich habe der eine hat schon
mal so gestreiften Pyjama an so das
mache ich jetzt hier mit allen dreien
und dann werden die halbiert den Ofen
habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 200
Grad Ober- und Unterhitze und ähm dann
müssen die erstmal ein bisschen vorgaren
und vor allem weich werden aber das
ganze nicht ohne alles sondern mit gutem
Olivenöl und Salz schön einreiben in den
Ofen geben und wir machen in der
Zwischenzeit die Füllung
[Musik]
so die Auberginen dürfen jetzt im Ofen
weich werden das dauert so ungefähr 30
bis 40 Minuten bei 200 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze es kommt natürlich immer
darauf an wie dick eure Auberginen sind
und ich bereite jetzt hier schon mal die
Füllung vor indem ich einfach erstmal
meine Zwiebeln
und ich habe auch schon alles bereit
gelegt und es wird heute es sind gar
nicht so viele Gewürze die wir brauchen
es ist so typisch türkisch und ihr
braucht generell für dieses Rezept
irgendwie keine exotischen Zutaten damit
viele Angst vor wenn ich in die Türkisch
koche oder so generell orientalisch
super easy also alles in den deutschen
Supermärkten gut das Fleisch hole ich
immer bei Metzger wenn es Vertrauens
muss ich dazu sagen aber ich werde jetzt
erstmal das Hackfleisch zusammen mit den
Zwiebeln und etwas Olivenöl in der
Pfanne richtig schön dünsten bzw ein
bisschen braten
[Musik]
so ich gebe jetzt hier noch Peperoni mit
dazu habe mir aber sechs Streifen für
die spätere Deko bei Seite gelegt und da
könnt ihr auch schon Paprika und
Tomatenmark mit dazugeben
[Musik]
so an der Stelle dürft ihr auch schon
mal würzen mit Salz Pfeffer und Pulver
ist türkisch und das sind paprikaflocken
das sind so typisch türkischen Paprika
ich nehme milder und ihr könnt
anschließend auch noch ein bisschen
Chili dazu geben wenn es schärfer mögt
was ich auch nebenbei gemacht habe ist
einmal die Tomaten quasi kreuzweise
aufgeschlitzt fünf Minuten den kochendes
Wasser gelegt und jetzt kann ich die
Schale ein bisschen einfacher entfernen
Würfel das und gibt das auch noch mit zu
Masse
[Musik]
so die Hackfleischfüllung ist fertig
wenn da jetzt keine Flüssigkeiten auf
dem Boden ist ich muss sagen meine
Tomaten waren jetzt nicht so wässrig
daher hat das bei mir nur ein bis zwei
Minuten gedauert sollte es richtig
wässrig sein dann lasst es gerne noch
mal so ein bisschen einreduzieren damit
es eben nicht ganz so flüssig auf die
Auberginen kommt die Aubergine habe ich
gerade aus dem Ofen geholt
so und ähm ich werde jetzt so machen
dass ich mir das in eine schöne
Auflaufform gebe und da werde ich dann
einfach die Aubergine so ein bisschen
Eindrücken und gleich habe ich noch
einen Tipp für euch ihr habt sicherlich
gemerkt dass noch kein Knoblauch zum
einen okay das ist nicht heißt das ist
halt so jetzt sicherlich gemerkt dass
noch kein Knoblauch zum Einsatz kam und
ich habe einen Trick von meiner Mama
gelernt das ist einfach ein bisschen
aromatischer oder auch viel aromatischer
wenn ihr den Knoblauch jetzt gleich erst
also ungefähr
auf die Aubergine gibt weil das ganze
kommt ja gleich noch mal in den Ofen und
dann schmeckt einfach noch aromatischer
so ein bisschen einfach in die
Auflaufform rein und dann wie gesagt
einfach mit der Gabel Eindrücken das ist
alles schön Oberland ist alles schön
weich geworden und dann den Knoblauch
einmal auf die Aubergine geben und dann
füllen wir das ganze mit unserer
Hackfleischfüllung
[Musik]
so wir sind fast fertig es fehlt noch
eine typisch türkische Tomatensoße und
die besteht aus einer drei Zutaten wir
haben ja einmal Tomatenmark Wasser dann
nehme ich gern schon heißes bzw warmes
könnt auch gerne gekochtes nehmen und
dann gebe ich dann noch Salz dazu und
dann wieder bei 200 Grad Ober und
Unterhitze im Ofen für weitere 20
Minuten garen und dann ist das Gericht
fertig ich mache übrigens parallel noch
Reis und was auch sehr gut dazu passt
ist Joghurt mit ein bisschen Salz und
ganz viel Knoblauch
[Musik]
ich habe einfach meine Deko vergessen
und zwar die schön zurecht geschnittenen
Peperoni strenge die gebe ich hier
einfach schön mit dazu und dann habe ich
hier noch Tomate gebe ich auch noch mit
dazu dass du diese typisch türkische
Deko und dann kommt aber wirklich in den
Ofen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das Nein türkisch
alles
diese ganzen Sachen
wir sind gar nicht so Gabel es war
tatsächlich
[Musik]
wertschätzendes Essen meines Gäste
kommen das macht einfach was her so ich
gönnen
so Reis mit alles Schöne ist man kann
sich da so ein bisschen vom
Fruchtfleisch von der Aubergine nehmen
also damals noch
nichts
ne das macht die Peperoni das macht das
Fleisch
gemacht
du brauchst nicht viele Gewürze bei
diesem Gericht ich glaube
ich muss sagen einige machen auch eine
ganze Aubergine im Ofen und schwitzen
die dann auf ich mag das nicht so ich
finde es automatisch ich bin weniger ist
deswegen
gesund
selber
gesprochen mit
Geschnetzeltes oder irgendwie eine
Alternative geht alles Leute
oder so dazu also ich wünsche euch ganz
viel Spaß beim Nachkochen hinterlasst
unserem Kanal ein kostenloses Abo wenn
ihr solche Rezepte nicht mehr verpassen
möchtet
vom Schuh hier
gehst du restaurant du kriegst du
niemals so ich muss sagen also
[Musik]